well I think it's what sarbanes-oxley
did well was to focus managerial
attention on accounting yet frankly in
the post sarbanes-oxley period you've
seen spectacular failures so it's not
getting people to dot i's and cross T's
isn't enough we really need to think
about risk management the area that I
think was not treated well enough in
sarbanes-oxley is the whole idea of
enterprise risk management with your
financial institution or a non financial
institution does the leadership of the
farm does the board of directors really
understand where the risks are buried in
firm I think in some of the recent
failures the answer to that question
might well be now
and that's so sure I think yeah I come
from Columbia where we have a whole
franchise teaching alternatives to the
efficient market hypothesis our students
a little bit different they come up with
behavioral approaches value investing
efficient markets is this one thing I
think that there was a tendency by many
policymakers and business people to
think of market prices must be better
than any available alternative I think
that there is clearly you need to look
at bubbles I don't think you can just
wait till after the fact and say oh my
gosh that was a bubble let's play it up
the housing bubble was quite clearly a
bubble I think it was noticed by a lot
of people who is noticed in real time
and does raise clear policy concerns I
don't think you can just say the market
price Calysta to run
I'm concerned about the politicization
of the Fed the Fed has been and is a
great institution is a central bank both
in conducting monetary policy and also
in being a great wind or a blast resort
I worried that drawing the Fed too much
into financial regulatory battles puts
it squarely in politics and it's clearly
an area where the Congress should have
and does have opinions I think the
committee on capital markets regulation
and part of his has issued an opinion
that having a an umbrella financial
services agency much like the United
Kingdom or Japan makes much more sense
for overall financial regulation and let
the feds stick the monetary policy
well I've always been sort of an odd man
out in Washington on this I don't
particularly think we should be
encouraging home ownership neither do i
think we should discourage home
ownership it seems to me that's an
economic decision for each individual to
make as a factual matter if you look at
the public policies that we've taken to
encourage home ownership of mortgage
interest deduction direct credit
interventions and so on there's very
little evidence to suggest that we
actually hire all ownership rates in
some countries that don't have a
mortgage interest deduction for example
our northern neighbor in Canada so I'm
not sure that it's worth the candle and
we know that what we put in through
fannie mae and freddie mac you know has
led to very large exposures to taxpayers
so i think this is a question we really
have to come to grips with ailee's don't
think there's a moral superiority to
homeownership I live that because I rent